j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
vous savez on cherche le plus souvent
possible à le décaler volontairement de
l'actualité du jour je vous propose un
retour sur cette annonce d'IBM c'était
il y a deux semaines le 2 mai le géant
américain annonce un gel des embauches
de métiers administrative pour prendre
le temps de définir ce qui pourrait être
remplacé par l'intelligence artificielle
avec l'IA le monde du travail est au
début d'une nouvelle révolution
bénéfique ou catastrophique avant d'en
débattre premier constat avec Audrey
betta ce qui nous emmène du côté de
Hollywood
merci beaucoup c'est peut-être le
premier conflit entre les humains et les
machines nous sommes à Hollywood et ses
scénaristes craignent que l'intelligence
artificielle ne vole leur travail la
righters gilt of America le principal
syndicat du secteur affirme ne pas être
opposé à l'utilisation de chat GPT pour
écrire un script à condition que
l'auteur en conserve la paternité un
affront pour les scénaristes
l'art ne peut pas être créé par une
machine nous vous perdez le cœur et
l'âme de l'histoire que vous racontez
dans intelligence artificielle il y a le
mot artificiel donc l'histoire sonnera
toujours artificielle ils veulent que
les ordinateurs et l'intelligence
artificielle remplace les vraies
personnes qui travaillent dur dans
certains domaines c'est presque déjà le
cas cette présentatrice de la chaîne
Koweït news n'existe pas elle est
générée par une intelligence
artificielle comme l'intégralité de ce
manga mais pour André gatolin qui
travaille sur le sujet de nombreux
autres domaines pourraient être
concernés il y a une étude de Goldman
Sachs assez récente qui parle d'un
potentiel de suppression de 300 millions
d'emplois dans le monde
horizons 2030 donc c'est considérable
parce que le problème c'est qu'on
analyse une technologie en soi avec les
impacts directs mais l'impact cumulé de
deux révolutions technologiques on peut
prendre l'intelligence artificielle et
la robotique peut conduire une
destruction encore plus massive dans
cette entreprise Amazon par exemple
l'alliance de la robotique et de
l'intelligence artificielle permet de se
passer de manutentionnaires mais le
vice-président de la branche se défend
de détruire des emplois au contraire
depuis 2012 nous avons créé un million
de nouveaux emplois dans le réseau
Amazon alors que dans le même temps nous
avons déployé plus de 500 000 robots
nous ne considérons donc pas que les
robots remplacent nécessairement les
personnes nous les voyons comme
travaillant à côté des personnes
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
nécessiter la création de métiers qui
n'existe pas pour l'instant mais il
reste une inconnue est-ce qu'ils
pourront remplacer la totalité des
postes supprimés
on en débat tout de suite avec Nicolas
Bouzou bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
fondateur du cabinet Asteres et
éditorialiste à L'Express auteur de ce
livre le travail et l'avenir de l'homme
publié aux éditions de l'Observatoire
Catherine Morin de saillie bonsoir
bienvenue à vous c'est matrice centriste
de la scène maritime et où vous êtes en
Paris de ces questions d'intelligence
artificielle ici au Sénat pierre cassuno
Guez bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
professeur de philosophie à l'Université
Paris 8 Vincennes Saint-Denis et ce
livre auteur de la bienveillance des
machines comment le numérique nous
transforme à notre insu puis pas publié
paru aux éditions du Seuil j'accueille
également en duplex en visioconférence
David Gruson qui est directeur du
programme santé de Luminess cofondateur
d'éthique.ia et membre de la chair santé
de Sciences Po Paris bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous Mathieu croissando
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
peut-être un premier constat Nicolas
Bouzou l'intelligence artificielle elle
est déjà présente
dans le monde du travail on peut même
dire depuis longtemps
ça change quoi la dernière j'ai les
dernières générations d'intelligence
artificielle et notamment chat gipiti
dont tout le monde parle depuis quelques
semaines je pense que ça va changer
beaucoup de choses parce que au fond
changeipy qui à mon avis et quelque
chose de très important c'est la
première fois qu'on a une application de
l'intelligence artificielle qui est pas
quelque chose d'abstrait et de théorique
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut l'utiliser à
titre personnel je l'utilise énormément
si vous voulez de mais depuis 15 jours
en fait donc c'est donc c'est très
récent et donc je pense dans une
entreprise aussi ah bah oui bien sûr
alors je pense que la question c'est de
savoir comment l'utiliser en gros vous
pouvez l'utiliser un petit peu comme un
moteur de recherche un peu plus
sophistiqué vous pouvez lui demander
voilà qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui au Sénat est-ce que tu peux
me faire une synthèse de ce qui s'est
passé au Sénat aujourd'hui mais ça je
dirais qu'on peut le faire autrement
moi par exemple quand je fais un papier
pour pour L'Express donc je fais mon
papier et je lui dis au fond est-ce que
j'aurais pas oublié quelque chose est-ce
qu'il y a pas une idée original que
j'aurais pas eu donc c'est très
intéressant mais évidemment il peut
faire de grosses bêtises il peut
commettre des contresens mais
pardonnez-moi d'avoir pris un exemple
personnel ça se fait pas mais mais c'est
juste pour vous expliquer que je pense
que pour la première fois on a vraiment
une application au fond qu'un très grand
nombre de nos concitoyens peuvent
utiliser et qui va changer les choses
juste je suis persuadé que cette
révolution qui essaie du numérique
d'intelligence artificielle de la
robotique et des biotechnologies c'est
la troisième révolution industrielle
c'est à dire qu'elle est aussi
importante que ce qu'on a connu au début
du 20e siècle avec la Belle Époque
l'automobile l'électricité etc ou au
XIXe siècle avec les machines à vapeur
le chemin de fer je suis persuadé que
c'est quelque chose de cette apprendre à
utiliser peut-être l'encadrer ça va
faire partie des questions qu'on va se
poser Catherine Morin le saillie c'est
peut-être un peu binaire ma question
est-ce que vous voyez qu'est-ce que
comment vous analysez cette montée en
puissance cette dernière génération
d'intelligence artificielle est-ce que
vous dites plutôt menaces plutôt
opportunité un peu tous les deux les
deux les deux d'ailleurs le règlement
sur l'intelligence artificielle que
l'Europe s'apprête à voter pour lequel
j'ai travaillé avec André catholin vous
avez entendu tout à l'heure s'exprimer
il vise tout simplement à la fois avoir
comment ça peut être un formidable outil
d'innovation et de progrès et en même
temps poser clairement des garde-fous
sur les mes usages de l'intelligence
artificielle une potentielle atteinte à
nos droits fondamentaux à la dignité de
l'homme si je prends un exemple très
concret ça peut être des formidables
progrès en matière de santé de médecine
mais ça peut être aussi un formidable
outil de surveillance de masse des
populations donc il faut que nous le
législateur le politique on fixe un
cadre c'est encore possible c'est pas
trop tard parce que là ça va tellement
vite ce n'est pas trop tard l'adoption
de ce de cette nouvelle technologie par
des millions de de d'humains c'est c'est
impressionnant
plutôt en avance par rapport au reste du
monde puisque elle va être la première
allégiférer à poser un cadre ambitieux
sur ce sur ce sujet aux États-Unis je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est dans
quelques états sur des segments de
l'intelligence artificielle qu'on a
légiférée il n'y a pas de législation
fédérale or on se rend compte vous avez
vu cette pétition des 1000
universitaires et personnalité investie
dans le développement de l'interdire
dans ses rivière de se poser la question
d'un moratoire pour qu'on ait le temps
justement de poser un cadre qui puisse
permettre voilà de poser une
intelligence artificielle artificielle
fiable éthique humaine en elle-même
l'intelligence elle est ni positive ni
négative c'est l'usage qu'on va en faire
qui va permettre de bien l'utiliser ou
non est-ce qu'il est encore temps père
castelier d'appuyer sur pause là
alors faut-il appuyer sur pause je suis
pas certain je pense qu'il est très
important d'essayer au moins d'encadrer
le développement de l'intelligence
artificielle en particulier la
surveillance à laquelle elle
peut donner lieu et le
voilà une catégorisation des individus
qui nous
enlève en fait une liberté mais alors là
on est dans les généralités pardon
j'essaie de ramener le débat sur
vraiment la question du travail parce
que notre thème c'est quand même les
emplois menacés ou pas menacés etc là il
y a enfin je le disais en lancement du
du sujet qu'on a regardé en ouverture de
ce débat il y a une décision très
concrète d'IBM
IBM dit on gèle les embauches des
emplois administratifs parce que on
considère que 30% de ses emplois vont
pouvoir être fait par l'intelligence
artificielle et ça c'est aujourd'hui
alors en ce qui concerne l'emploi
bon je pense qu'il y a beaucoup un
déplacement des tâches mais lorsqu'il y
a suppression humaine c'est-à-dire
lorsqu'une machine fait le travail d'un
humain pour moi c'est une excellente
chose ça veut dire que cette tâche elle
n'était pas vraiment humaine en fait
elle était mécanique qu'elle n'exprimait
pas ce qu'il y a d'humain en nous
c'était une aliénation et la question
c'est socialement je vous trouve bien la
question c'est socialement mais d'être
capable de rémunérer le loisir ou de
distribuer équitablement le loisir ainsi
gagner mais au supermarché voilà il y a
des caisses automatiques en gros un
caissier ou une caissière peut s'occuper
surveiller 10 caisses automatiques ça
veut dire il y a 9 caissiers dont on a
plus besoin comme caissier et ben ça
leur permet de faire autre chose et la
seule pour moi la seule je trouve que
c'est une excellente chose et la seule
et la question par contre sociale et
politique c'est d'être capable de
rémunérer le temps libre qu'ils ont
gagné mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire une société sans travail finalement
ça veut dire une société où on travaille
moins effectivement et où on est à la
fois capable idéologiquement
accepter de ne pas travailler c'est pas
si simple en fait qu'on se sent coupable
de ne pas travailler mais aussi une
société ou socialement on rémunère on
donne un revenu décent à des des gens
qui ne travaillent pas vous êtes
d'accord ou pas d'accord parce que le
titre de votre risque c'est le travail
et l'avenir de l'homme donc il faut
rester il va disparaître ou alors là je
suis le travail ne disparaîtra pas bah
si les machines nous remplacent non mais
les machines vont pas vous remplacer je
vous rassure déjà alors j'entends le
métier de journaliste on peut se poser
la question
dans lequel l'intelligence artificielle
est pas si mauvais c'est autre chose
autre chose non non c'est la distinction
très 30% des journalistes qui perdent
leur emploi parce que une intelligence
artificielle est plus efficace écoute
moins cher bah non c'est pas autre chose
allez-y bon déjà quand vous regardez les
choses historiquement il y a très peu de
métiers qui disparaissent en raison de
la technologie il y en a mais c'est
extrêmement rare ce que fait la
technologie c'est qu'elle supprime des
tâches beaucoup plus que des métiers et
donc je peux vous le dire dans 10 ans ou
dans 20 ans il y aura des médecins il y
aura des enseignants et il y aura des
journalistes voilà en revanche que font
ces médecins que font ces enseignants
que font ces journalistes ça c'est
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
compliqué donc on peut toujours se faire
peur je vois les études des banques on
va perdre 300 millions d'emplois oui
pourquoi pas 2 milliards 5 milliards
d'emplois on peut raconter tout et
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs les mêmes
études disent on n'en sait rien ils nous
disent on va perdre 80 % des emplois
donc ça on ne peut absolument pas le
savoir en revanche notre grand sujet de
réflexion aujourd'hui très concret vous
demandiez d'être concret c'est un
médecin dans 10 ans avec l'intelligence
artificielle un chirurgien avec la
robotique qu'est-ce qu'il va faire dans
10 ans comment on le forme aujourd'hui
assez à ces outils comme on modifie
l'enseignement l'université etc et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je suis ravi que
des sénateurs et des parlementaires en
règle générale s'empare de ces dossiers
parce que allez je peux pas m'empêcher
de faire un peu de provocation ça me
semble plus important beaucoup plus
important pour l'avenir que tous les
débats un peu traumatisants qu'on a eu
ces deux ou trois dernières mois sur sur
la réforme
vous pourriez venir alors vous parliez
de santé justement en a David Gouzon qui
est avec nous
l'intelligence artificielle elle est
déjà présente j'allais dire
omniprésente c'est quoi c'est un outil
qui est utilisé pour améliorer le
diagnostic par exemple je crois pour des
chirurgiens qui répètent une opération
par exemple avant de la faire pour de
bon
c'est absolument et c'est d'ailleurs un
des sujets qu'on suit avec avec Nicolas
Bouzou un peu tous les ans dans les
rencontres de l'avenir à Saint-Raphaël
c'est un sujet qu'on suit avec etia et
on a analysé les effets de l'IA sur le
sur le sur l'emploi c'est une étude qui
avait été faite déjà il y a quelques
années avec l'Institut Montaigne et dont
les constats et la révolution qu'on voit
avec chaque GPT sur ce qu'on appelle lia
générative il y a de nouvelles
générations renforce ses analyses en
fait ce qui est concerné c'est d'abord
ce qu'on appelle les fonctions supports
du système les fonctions logistiques
techniques les émissions de patients des
fonctions administratives tout ce qui ne
concerne pas directement la prise en
charge
et cette il y a aujourd'hui elle libère
du temps pour pour les soignants sur des
fonctions tout à fait
identifiées la reconnaissance d'image en
traumatologie en ophtalmologie en
dermatologie on a des nouvelles méthodes
d'accès aux soins qui se mettent en
place qui génèrent et ça c'est tout à
fait important de le considérer un
besoin d'adaptation des emplois se
rejoint le conseil Nicolas Bouzou on va
avoir peut-être moins une disparition de
métier qu'une transformation de ces
métiers et il faut constater que des
démarches ont été faites pour développer
la formation alia dans les formations
médicales et soignantes en revanche on
n'a pas encore de plan d'adaptation des
emplois et des compétences pour des
secrétaires médicales pour les
brancardiers pour les fonctions
logistiques médico-technique dont les
emplois sont tout à fait radicalement
transformés donc là il faut engager
pardon nous interrompre c'est toujours
l'exemple qu'on donne donc j'imagine que
vous avez la l'habitude de répondre mais
le métier de radiologue par exemple le
l'oeil de l'ordinateur il est bien plus
précis que l’œil humain donc est-ce que
ce métier va disparaître au profit des
intelligence artificielle
il se transforment exemple de protocoles
que nous déployons avec avec etikia sur
des solutions via de reconnaissance
d'image de fractures donc ces solutions
aujourd'hui elles sont déployées dans
toute une série d'établissements en
France qui utilisent des solutions de
reconnaissance d'images de fracture qui
sont utilisés dans le temps de la prise
en charge la nuit aux urgences par les
équipes d'urgence les médecins
urgentistes et des infirmières sont la
présence du radiologue il y a va donner
un premier avis et le radiologue va
pouvoir en temps réel en cas de doute
mais plus un posteriori assurer un
contrôle humain une garantie humaine
c'est la notion fondamentale du
règlement européen sur l'IACS que Madame
Morin de Seille mentionné on peut amener
un accès aux soins plus fort et voyez le
métier de radiologue il se transforme il
a inspire il analyse une image en temps
réel la nuit il a une capacité à
retrouver du temps disponible et on sait
que dans des spécialités médicales en
tension des équipes comme la radiologie
il est majeur de redonner du temps au
médecin donc l'exercice se transforme et
il faut accompagner deuxième mouvement
et en mesurait les effets alors merci
merci je reviendrai vers vous évidemment
un peu plus tard on va je vous propose à
Mathias Arras de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau parce qu'on va essayer de lister
un peu plus précisément les les métiers
rebonsoir Mathias
susceptible d'être menacé ou de devoir
se transformer alors sans surprise ce
sont des métiers dit en col blanc selon
Erwan tison directeur de l'Institut
sapiens plus le coup est faible moins
l'intérêt de remplacer le travailleur
par une machine est élevée donc dans une
étude initié conjointement par les
universités d'Oxford et de Yale en 2017
on apprend par exemple que des 2049 des
programmes informatiques seront en
capacité de rédiger des livres complets
en 2053 certaines tâches de chirurgien
pourrait être aussi être réalisés alors
parmi les métiers menacés on trouve par
exemple employé de banque qui pourrait
disparaître d'ici 2038 comptables entre
2041 et 2056 juriste et avocat et bien
d'autres à des horizons similaire alors
il est difficile de savoir précisément
combien de personnes cela concerne parce
qu'il existe différentes estimations
alors on peut prendre les optimistes
comme celle du Forum économique mondial
qui prévoit que l'intelligence
artificielle pourrait créer à horizon
2027 c'est demain près de 69 millions de
postes de travail mais en détruirait en
revanche 803 soit une perte sèche de 14
millions d'emplois et il y a les moins
optimistes aussi comme les petits de
Goldman Sachs qui parlent de 300
millions d'emplois qui pourraient
disparaître dans le monde alors est-ce
qu'à l'inverse il y a des métiers qui
n'ont pas de souci à se faire alors il y
a une liste de 34 métiers qui ne
disparaîtront jamais elle a été produite
par open hei le fameux développeur de
tiaggy piti alors je vous en cite 10
vous avez peut-être des proches autour
de la table qui travaillent là-dedans il
y a abateur et emballeur de viande aide
couvreur maçon carreleur aide menuisier
peintre plombier athlètes compétiteur
sportive voilà il y en a peut-être
autour de la table boulonneur de toi
dans l'industrie dans l'industrie
minière pardon coiffeur conducteur les
engins de surface et de damage et j'en
passe puisqu'il y en a 34 autant de
métiers manuels qui ne devrait pas avoir
de soucis à se faire je dis bien de vrai
car l'inconnu bien le réside dans le
fait que la convergence entre les
révolutions de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la robotique et bien
on ne sait pas pourquoi pas imaginer un
jour qu'une
Ia contrôle un robot qui vous coupe les
cheveux mais ce qu'on est prêt pour ce
tournant alors c'est pas de manière
égale on n'est pas tous égaux récemment
le centre européen pour le développement
de la formation alerté sur le retard
accumulé par certains pays face à ces
évolutions de l'emploi et en tête des
pays européens les plus en danger on
retrouve la France qui voit son nombre
d'emplois menacer augmenter après de 2,3
millions c'est en rouge sur la carte
parce que avant et bien c'était à 2,1
millions et alors face à ça il y a deux
écoles de pensée la première qui est de
plus en plus répandue elle émane des
propres acteurs de la tech Mustapha
Souleymane qui est le co-fondateur de
Deep mind aujourd'hui intégré à Google
il plaide pour une compensation
matérielle Lisée entre les lignes une
sorte de revenu universel une
proposition qui est d'ailleurs soutenue
par Elon Musk et puis une autre qui est
poussé plutôt par les acteurs
économiques les plus libéraux comme le
Forum économique mondial ce serait de
donner un coup d'accélérateur sur la
reconversion professionnelle pour les
métiers les plus menacés merci beaucoup
mathiasa alors pour ces explications
il fallait les prendre avec avec
prudence on entend ça et évidemment
Catherine Morin de saillie vous nous
avez dit que l'Europe était en première
ligne sur
l'encadrement finalement la régulation
effectivement est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
au contraire être entre la première
ligne sur l'accompagnement des startups
de l'intelligence artificielle le
l'ambition de créer un géant mondial de
l'intelligence artificielle vous voyez
ce que je veux dire il faut pousser les
deux curseurs en même temps
que nous soyons précurseurs et regardez
comme étant justement
une référence dans ce modèle en matière
de régulation c'est très bien on est à
quelques sens c'est ce que disait
Francis Hogen la lanceur d'alerte de
facebook quand elle est venue au Sénat
elle a dit en quelque sorte les rgpd qui
va contrôler nos données permettre la
production de données c'est l'étalon
d'or mondiales bon il faut pousser sur
curseur le plus loin possible et que
nous soyons une référence entre un
modèle c'est très bien mais sauf que les
premières les premiers à entre
guillemets je dis pas à souffrir
potentiellement de cette réglementation
ce sont les startups françaises et
européennes qui vont être les premières
à l'appliquer donc à côté de distorsion
de concurrence par rapport aux autres
premièrement on n'a pas pas su mettre en
place des conditions de réformer notre
législation de la concurrence celle-ci
se fait au détriment en effet notre
propre industrie européenne on a passé
non plus dictée des règles pour créer et
faire monter en puissance un écosystème
européen comme on fait les Américains
les Russes les Chinois on a au Brésil
assumer une préférence communautaire
c'est-à-dire par exemple l'industrie de
l'informatique en nuage ce qu'on appelle
le Cloud c'est à peu près 500 000
emplois dans les quelques années à venir
on a vu qu'avec la dématérialisation qui
s'est accéléré pendant la crise du covid
on a besoin de cette informatique en
nuage et bien le sujet devrait être de
permettre d'accompagner toutes ces
entreprises du Cloud et clouder européen
d'abord parce que traiter au niveau
Européen par des entreprises européennes
qui respectent nos standards nos
fondamentaux c'est s'assurer de la
protection de nos données que ce soit
les données des administrations
personnelles privées ou des entreprises
donc ce qu'il faut c'est pousser cette
industrie créer les conditions réformer
notre législation la concurrence pour
favoriser ces entreprises parce que le
sujet de l'intelligence artificielle ce
sont en fait les bagarres que se lèvent
ce que ce livre les grandes entreprises
pour capter en fait ce marché qui était
extrêmement rentable donc si ce marché
doit encore tomber dans l'escarcelle des
big tech et bien en effet on sera
pénalise on a bien compris Mathieu
pardon mais est-ce que c'est pas un
combat perdu d'avance et est-ce qu'on
sait bien ce qui va arriver on n'est pas
fichu de de régler le problème d'accès
des sites pornographiques pour des
enfants de moins de 18 ans et là on
pourrait réguler une intelligence
artificielle au niveau européen ou
mondial pour
j'ai du mal à y croire moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on vit une révolution
industriel colossal le numérique c'était
un mélange de révolution c'est
l'invention d'imprimerie l'invention de
l'électricité numérique c'est-à-dire que
ça c'est une formidable diffusion de la
connaissance et puis c'est un formidable
bouleversement de modèle économique là
on y ajoute la révolution des données et
qui vont être assimilés est-ce qu'on
sait bien est-ce qu'on mesure est-ce
qu'on est incapacité de mesurer ce que
ça peut donner vous disiez les chiffres
on les connaît pas moi sur la volonté du
politique d'encadrer une révolution
pareille qui est en train de se lancer
alors que on sait bien qu'il y a pas de
normes mondial de l'Internet qui a pas
de normes mondial du numérique que on
n'arrive pas à
bord des protocoles et descend là le
tout c'est que l'Europe il pèse
définition c'est c'est un monde virtuel
sur lequel comment vous sans doute c'est
une vision de bossien et comment vous
législateur en France vous allez pouvoir
réguler l'intelligence artificielle a
déjà fait ses preuves pardonnez-moi de
le dire et encadrer
en général protection des données
on ne peut pas et on a des autorités de
régulation dans chaque État membre et au
niveau européen pour faire en sorte que
on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi avec
les données des des Européens et ça
c'est très important puisque c'est la
donnée qui est le regard du numérique
qui nourrit toute cette nouvelle
économie toutes ces nouvelles
technologies donc le vrai sujet c'est
comment nous régulons l'accès à ces
données faut pas être pessimiste sur le
fait que l'on ne peut pas réguler ça je
m'inscris complètement faux en revanche
il faut que ça soit concomitant avec une
vraie volonté de politique industrielle
pour se doter peut-être certaines
briques d'un écosystème européen propre
alors je reviens au métier
potentiellement menacé ou qui devront se
transformer je prends les deux arguments
vous nous dit tout à l'heure que
finalement si c'était si l'intelligence
artificielle pouvait remplacer l'humain
c'est que le métier était pas forcément
intéressant grosso modo c'est ce que
c'est ce que vous dites alors moi j'ai
une vraie question autour des métiers de
la création des métiers artistiques qui
sont aussi menacé ou challenger pardon
pour l'anglicisme par par l'intelligence
artificielle et notamment la dernière
génération un témoignage tiens un
scénariste américain scénariste de série
télé ils sont en plein bras de fer avec
Hollywood et dans ce bras de fer il y a
la question de l'intelligence
artificielle il manifeste cette joie
devant apparemment après une échec de
négociation l'écoute nous ne voulons pas
avoir réécrire ce qu'une intelligence
artificielle a inventée nous ne voulons
pas que nos œuvres soient introduites
dans une intelligence artificielle pour
qu'elle puisse les utiliser de bien des
façons comme le plagiat nous ne voulons
pas que les entreprises décident que
l'intelligence artificielle peut nous
remplacer parce que ça leur coûterait
moins cher et tant mieux pour eux c'est
une décision commerciale intelligente et
ce n'est pas une décision humaine alors
ça existe déjà on va pas être angélique
dans l'industrie du disque ou du ou du
cinéma la tentation de faire des
produits un peu standardisés mais alors
là on est on pousse le curseur encore un
peu plus loin alors il y a deux choses
différentes ce que fait le mieux
challenge j'ai pété c'est un algorithme
qui à partir de mots déjà utilisés lance
les plus probables donc ce que fait chat
GPT c'est le langage le plus probable le
langage le plus banal donc par exemple
vous lui donnez un courrier électronique
chat GPT réponds-moi à ce courrier
électronique il le fait très bien vous
lui donnez les caractéristiques d'un
appartement il est créé une annonce
immobilière parfaite parce que dans les
deux cas c'est juste c'est un langage
banal qui qui l'utilise et donc là il le
fait parfaitement c'est tout à fait
intéressant et on peut et on peut se
demander ce que va devenir l'écrit ainsi
finalement c'est un algorithme qui fait
mon courrier électronique un autre
algorithme qui répond est-ce que
finalement l'écrit va rester mais il
s'agit pas vraiment de création
lorsqu'on a de là il s'agit de création
par exemple les machines génératives et
on a beaucoup parlé dans la presse des
illustrateurs en fait qui seraient
remplacés par Dali ou midjorn en fait
donc là c'est des machines à créer des
images qui génère des images et qui très
vraiment incroyable mais c'est pas c'est
justement ce que vous disiez c'est à
dire que la tâche de l'illustrateur est
transformée et au lieu de dessiner il va
choisir des pompes des mots à mettre
dans l'algorithme pour lui faire faire
une image et puis voyant l'image il va
dire bah non le côté gauche c'est pas
parfait je les fasse je fais remplacer
il y aura plus jamais besoin de
dessinateur et ben c'est un autre
travail c'est un autre travail mais
c'est pas qu'il y a plus besoin de
l'humain c'est d'une certaine façon que
l'algorithme c'est un outil comme
finalement le pinceau ben le pinceau en
gros ça fait longtemps qu'on ne met plus
simplement la main sur la paroi de la
grotte et qu'on utilise des outils pour
créer et bien là l'intelligence
artificielle c'est un autre outil et un
outil qui permet de faire derrière un
appauvrissement des capacités de
l'humain
alors quand moi ça me fait moi je ne
sais pas dessiner mais d'un seul coup je
vais utiliser les logiciels où vous
parliez et puis je vais pouvoir créer
une
œuvre qui semblera magnifique à tout le
monde sauf qu'en fait j'aurais juste
donné trois mots clés à mon avis c'est
vraiment une transformation de de des
activités humaines et par exemple à moi
ce qui me fascine c'est l'idée que tout
ce langage banal qu'on utilise en
particulier le courriel je reçois un
courriel chacun reçoit beaucoup je
réponds une réponse type que en fait si
des algorithmes peuvent être capables de
le faire et au lieu de et de mettre
directement le rendez-vous dans mon
agenda parce qu'il y a une case libre
finalement on en soit débarrassé et que
donc on la fonction véritablement du
langage se transforme et je pense pas
que ça veut dire qu'on qu'on crée moins
ou qu'on
c'est une autre façon d'être humain et
dans le cas du dessin c'est une autre
façon de produire des images c'est aussi
la question des droits d'auteur Nicolas
Bouzou parce que là il me dit mais
attendez la machine je simplifie
volontairement elle se nourrit de nos
scénarios pour ensuite en pondre des
scénarios sur lesquels on sera obligé de
retravailler donc le message là a
toujours fonctionné comme ça si vous
êtes mélomane vous savez très bien que
la musique classique est vraiment
d'emprunt etc donc ça il y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil en fait ce que je
trouve ce débat je l'ai dit fondamental
et passionnant mais je pense que à
vouloir se faire peur en réalité en se
disant il y a plein de métiers qui vont
disparaître certains vous disent aussi
que les machines vont se retourner
contre nous et nous détruire etc je
pense que on loupe les vrais enjeux et
les vrais débats il faut essayer je dis
à tout celles et ceux qui nous regardent
il faut essayer pour bien comprendre
quel est l'enjeu l'enjeu il y a eu un
article remarquable de Pierre BENTATA
qui est économise dans le Figaro ces
derniers jours qui explique très bien et
c'est ce que vous disiez que utiliser
l'agence artificielle c'est arriver à
dialoguer avec l'intelligence
artificielle
de comprendre ce qu'est l'attend ce
qu'elle peut nous apporter ses limites
et vous savez quelle est la principale
compétence pour faire ça la principale
compétence pour pouvoir utiliser une
intelligence artificielle c'est savoir
s'exprimer en français comprendre le
français s'exprimer en français et donc
il faut revenir waouh enfin je disais en
français dans une autre langue en
fonction et donc vous comprenez bien et
l'enjeu à mon sens fondamental il est là
ces intelligences artificielles ce sont
des formes moi je compare ça un peu un
exosquelette si vous voulez c'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez faire tout un tas de
choses plus fort mieux mais si vous ne
savez pas les utiliser là vous risquez
de rester sur sur le bord du chemin et
l'enjeu il est là moi je reviens sur la
question de la des artistes des
créateurs dans Les Echos ce matin vous
l'avez peut-être lui il y a
Jean-Philippe thielée qui est président
du Centre national de la musique qui
signe une tribu de le titre c'est le
cauchemar d'une musique sans musicien il
explique que finalement c'est une
question de coût une musique créée par
l'intelligence artificielle à partir de
millions de muscles vous le dites
finalement on a toujours c'est toujours
des emprun TS à partir de millions de
musiques passées ça coûtera toujours
moins cher que de payer à que de payer
un humain pour créer pour créer un
morceau et mais non enfin
les gens vous pouvez pas savoir ce
qu'ils attendent en matière de musique
je vais y prendre un exemple pour le
rassurer
il y a 100000 nouveaux titres qui
sortent chaque jour sur les plateformes
de streaming et une large part de ses
100.000 nouveaux titres elle ils sont
créés justement par des machines par de
l'intelligence artificielle et voilà
comment les humains comment les humains
essaient de créer des nouveaux morceaux
il se différencie et ils se font marquer
dans ce flot de nouveaux morceaux qui
nous tombe dessus chaque jour et jamais
il n'y a eu autant dans le monde de
billets de spectacle de concerts vendus
jamais à des prix aussi élevés voilà
donc et juste juste un sens sur la
question de la création alors
pardonnez-moi je cite un autre article
encore du Figaro mais dorellijan qui est
une spécialiste de sujet qui expliquait
extrêmement bien qu'en fait
l'intelligence artificielle peut créer
mais elle ne peut pas procéder à une
révolution artistique très exactement
pour la raison que vous évoquez
c'est-à-dire que l'intelligence
artificielle elle utilise au fond un
vocabulaire des elle se base sur
l'existant mais elle ne peut pas faire
du Wagner si vous voulez elle peut pas
rompre véritablement donc là encore je
pense qu'il voilà il faut se relaxer par
rapport à tout ça mais en revanche
l'enjeu
je suis moins optimiste que vous et je
pense que comme souvent on a on a un
deux ou trois métros de retard par
rapport à une nouvelle technologie parce
que on n'a pas de la capture combien
d'entre nous alors vous le voulez
utiliser mais ça vraiment l'utiliser bon
prenons le cas de la musique
on aura toujours besoin d'interprète
l'expérience du concert du spectacle
vivant en direct on est plus sur les
tablettes pardon vous prenez un casque
de réalité virtuelle vous allez vous
assistez à un concept pas besoin de vous
déplacer il a plus des nuances le chef
selon son humeur selon sa sensibilité
l'interprétation du morceau c'est pas la
machine qui va pouvoir la création du
morceau
rien ne remplacera le médecin dans son
humanité à dialoguer avec son patient
pour le comprendre profondément dans ses
émotions et sa psychologie qui va
l'aider à guérir donc j'ai envie de dire
la part d'humanité elle va rester il
faut qu'elle reste pour maîtriser la
machine qu'il faut qu'il doit être
considéré comme un outil
pourquoi pas qui va permettre de créer
de nouveaux formats de nouvelles oeuvres
la seule chose c'est que ça lui sent des
artistes et à la question du droit
d'auteur de la propriété intellectuelle
autrement dit ça renvoie au sujet est-ce
que tout ce qui a été les outils qui ont
servi les images les textes qui ont
servi à créer ont été acquis de manière
licite c'est toujours la question des
données voilà c'est ça je crois que ça
peut tout à fait se réguler également il
n'y avait on y avait dans notre projet
de de
résolutions européenne pour
l'intelligence artificielle voilà mais
la part d'humanité dieu merci justement
elle ne espérons le lapin il ne faut pas
qu'il se passe
les médecins ils vont tous devenir psy
finalement ou accompagnateurs de de
thérapie puisque les machines font le
reste
effectivement il faut aussi considérer
que lia fait progresser l'humain parce
que elle amène et c'est ce qu'on voit
dans les protocoles pour toi et médecins
aussi à reconsidérer un certain nombre
de leurs pratiques dans le règlement
européen survia qui était mentionné il y
a cette notion de garantie humaine de
contrôle humain qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire concrètement on en est nous à une
douzaine d'écosystèmes de supervision
humaine de Lia qui sont animés dans
toute une série spécialités ou de
manière régulière on va avec des
médecins mais aussi c'est très important
des représentants des patients revoir
des situations traitées par l'IA dans
les soins bucco-dentaires en
anatomopathologie dans le domaine de
l'ophtalmologie et ça mène à
réinterroger les pratiques et à
réinterroger aussi un besoin de
formation continue et là dedans le le
dialogue avec les patients l'empathie la
manière de reconsidérer la manière de
s'exprimer est et donc ce dialogue qui
est créé autour de l'usage de la machine
il a aussi une vocation de
d'amélioration continue des pratiques et
on voit que l'humain peut aussi être un
peu trop mécanique dans sa pratique et
le fait de réinterroger l'outil via à la
faveur de cette obligation alors c'est
une obligation qui va être lourdement
fonctionné à partir de 2025 il y a pas
de contrôle humain sur des systèmes liés
en santé les concepteur est utilisateurs
en courant des fonctions jusqu'à 4% de
leur chiffre d'affaires mais l'Europe
est en avance sur la régulation et c'est
pas forcément un problème en soi
d'ailleurs le les États-Unis ont suivi
cette idée de supervision humaine demain
à Marseille l'agence de sécurité
sanitaire américaine a repris cette idée
issu de la loi de bioéthique française
et du règlement européen sur l'Yonne
faut l'appliquer par anticipation mais
dans un esprit intelligent qu'un esprit
le dialogue autour de l'usage de la
machine c'est ça de votre plan central
c'est désolé mais il y a une ambiance
autour de vous on a l'impression qu'une
intelligence artificielle c'est celle à
la musique de décaphonique bref c'est
c'est ça ne facilite pas la
compréhension de de votre démonstration
je reviendrai vers vous j'espère qu'on
va améliorer ça ou si vous pouvez faire
passer le message autour de vous de
calmer un peu le jeu je sais pas qui
joue du tambour mais bref on vous entend
pas très bien Matthieu je voudrais qu'on
prenne le temps avec vous de voir
comment le le chat parce que c'est on va
dire la nouvelle star de la
l'intelligence artificielle fait
irruption à se faire politique pour
l'instant une avancée timide avec un
regard pour le moins circonspect de la
part d'une classe politique qui regarde
ce nouvel outil un peu comme une poule
qui aurait trouvé un couteau le 12 avril
dernier en marge de sa visite au
Pays-Bas Emmanuel Macron s'y essaye en
un mot comment se place l'Europe dans
les technologies de rupture demande-t-il
à gipiti réponse du robot
conversationnel compétitive résultat qui
comble le locataire de l'Élysée qui se
font aussitôt d'un tweet présidentiel
comme vous pouvez le voir ce qui lui
vaut illico une flopée de réponse
sarcastique ou parodique en un mot
comment se place la France dans le
respect du droit de manifester demande
en internaute mitigé répond le robot en
un mot Emmanuel Macron a-t-il respecté
le cerveau de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat non réponse
là vous avez compris cinq jours plus
tard au soir de l'allocution télévisée
du chef de l'État c'est vous savez après
la réforme des retraites c'est autour de
Sophie Binet la patronne de la CGT
d'ironiser sur le caractère désincarné
de la prestation d'Emmanuel Macron bah
en fait la question qu'on se pose c'est
sur quelle planète vie Emmanuel Macron
c'était locution aurait pu être faite
par chat gipiti il a pas trop de la CGT
personne ne l'utilise vraiment pour
l'instant si alors le 2 avril dernier
euh le député socialiste de l'art de
service Soulignac interpelle le ministre
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique Jean-Noël Barraud regardez il
pose sa question d'abord ouais vous
interroger sur la montée en puissance de
l'intelligence artificielle les
évolutions des dernières semaines sont
particulièrement impressionnantes
donc là il pose sa question réponse du
ministre et puis il reprend la parole
Hervé Soulignac écoutait merci monsieur
le ministre vous venez de répondre à cet
instant au 578e député puisque la
question que je viens de vous poser a
été entièrement rédigée par chat GPT
donc c'est vrai que pour poser des
questions interpeller les ministres sur
des sujets techniques et pas forcément
politique
cette démonstration par l'absurde rares
sont les politiques à ses aides vraiment
appropriées tiens s'il y en a un c'était
aujourd'hui vous savez qui Éric Zemmour
qui a lancé son robot conférérationnel
flambant neuf ça s'appelle chazed alors
vous me connaissez j'ai évidemment
essayé je lui ai demandé par exemple ce
qu'il proposait pour réformer les
retraites et que ce que me répondent
Shutz
Eric Zemmour souhaite porter l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans à
l'horizon 2030 je vais c'est pas déjà
fait ça je croyais que ça avait été fait
comme quoi hein en fait c'est juste la
recyclage de la composition de son
programme de l'an dernier je disais
comme quoi c'est pas forcément dans les
vieux pots qu'on fait les meilleurs
soupes mais dans les nouveaux pots qu'on
trouve de vieilles idées et ça pose
merci Mathieu ça pose la question de
l'utilisation effectivement ou des
erreurs qu'on peut trouver quand on
utilise cette nouvelle génération
l'intelligence artificielle tient vous
inciter deux fois le Figaro je vais
citer deux fois les échos Gaspard kenix
dans une tribune publiée dans Les Echos
aujourd'hui il nous raconte il a demandé
à chat GPT de recenser les idées des
philosophes sur le compost on n'est pas
pourquoi il lui cette idée mais bref
c'est ça et l'intelligence artificielle
lui fournit une longue citation de
Jean-Jacques Rousseau tiré du livre 4 de
l'Émile donc qu'est-ce qui fait il va
dans le livre de 4 de l'Émile c'était
paix il cherche il cherche la citation
en question après vérification elle
n'existe pas en fait l'intelligence
avative avec créé toute pièce une sorte
de patchwork avec des mots qui peuvent
être les mots doux soit des idées qui
peuvent être les idées de ressources
sauf que la citation elle n'existait pas
comment on peut faire confiance et là je
reviens au monde du travail c'est-à-dire
et ça pose la question de la formation
générale à l'usage de l'intelligence
artificielle mais là je reste sur la
question des une entreprise qui dit à
ses salariés vous pouvez utiliser tchat
député ou les équivalents sauf que s'il
y a des erreurs dedans on fait comment
qui est responsable le salarié ou
l'entreprise de les rendre en question
justement c'est bien ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire qu'il
faut apprendre à utiliser ces
intelligences artificielles qui
commettent des erreurs exactement de la
même façon que les humains commettent
des erreurs parce que l'article de
Gaspard kenigamusant mais je peux
demander aussi à des professeurs de
philosophie de m'expliquer ce que
Rousseau pense du compost il est
possible aussi que certains se trompent
oui mais là elle lui donne
l'intelligence c'est pas la même
justement parce que que
s'il est en état de confiance en
d'autres il va la reprendre elle va être
estampillée Gaspard Kelly donc d'un seul
coup ses étudiants ou d'autres vont
pouvoir la reprendre
c'est-à-dire que quand on est bien
travaillé ça lui demande encore plus de
temps et donc le temps qu'on est censé
gagner avec l'intelligence artificielle
on le perd pour vérifier ce qu'elle nous
propose alors je ne suis pas sûr que ça
fasse gagner du temps je pense que ça
peut permettre d'aller beaucoup plus
loin dans un certain nombre de choses je
vous l'ai dit je je pense que c'est pas
la meilleure demander ce que Rousseau
pense du compost je suis pas sûr que ce
soit la bonne utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle en revanche
David Gouzon et spécialiste de ça une
intelligence artificielle qui aura vu
des millions de mélanome des milliards
de beauté avec un deuxième avis d'un
médecin là je peux vous assurer que on
aura réussi à avancer donc donc voilà ce
que vous dites tout à l'heure il faut
Jean-Noël Barrault aussi ministre du
numérique quelqu'un que j'aime bien par
ailleurs mais qui avait expliqué que
tchadipiti je le cite est un perroquet
approximatif je pense que c'est
complètement à côté du sujet puisque je
voudrais vous dire c'est que l'effort
qu'on doit faire on est ici pour
réfléchir c'est de se projeter à
l'horizon de 10 ans regardez les progrès
extraordinaires entre la version 3 et la
version 4 de chat gipiti il y a eu
combien de temps entre les deux quelques
mois en réalité là la question qu'on
doit se poser c'est aujourd'hui des des
jeunes qui sont au lycée qui vont
intégrer le marché du travail dans 5 à
10 ans ou en scratchippy c'est ça la
machine se nourrit plus utilisé plus
elle devient intelligente on est
d'accord c'est le principe si vous aviez
été remplacé par un robot
conversationnel pour animer ce débat ton
Mailloux serait eu la qualité
que nous avons je dis ça parce que on a
eu un débat sur l'intelligence
artificielle justement c'est sur les
conséquences en matière d'emploi social
politique économique etc moi j'ai
préparé mon intervention de 4 minutes
avec chat JPY c'était fade des incarnés
son nuances mécanique aujourd'hui
comme dit Nicolas bozou c'est pas sûr
peut-être pas
l'accélération de de l'apprentissage de
de cette intelligence artificielle et
Faramine c'est ce que vous nous dites
par principe c'est la façon de
fonctionner il fait ce qui est le plus
probable donc par principe ce sera banal
donc ça ne peut-il dénominateur commun
c'est le plus commun et donc ça ne peut
que rester sans
sans inventivité
et donc voilà ça ça
s'est vu les images elles sont
bluffantes oui alors c'est c'est un peu
différent entre une un texte et une
image c'est pas pareil parce que une
image vous avez entre le pixel qui est
donné où toute une série de pixels qui
sont données et le suivant vous avez
beaucoup plus de liberté que vous avez
dans un texte en fait bon et donc avec
une image vous pouvez avoir quelque
chose de surréaliste à tous vous l'avez
compris j'ai je vais le rôle de
lentilles
parce que vous étiez tous un peu sur la
même ligne donc il fallait bien
quelqu'un pour vous titiller mais je
suis prêt à utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle à condition d'être bien
formé merci Mathieu d'avoir participé à
ce débat merci à tous je rappelle le
titre de vos livres Nicolas Bouzou le
travail et l'avenir de l'homme c'est aux
éditions de l'Observatoire pierre
cassuno Guess l'a bienveillance des
machines comment le numérique nous
transforme à notre insu aux éditions du
Seuil je vous dis à lundi merci à toutes
et à tous de votre fidélité et puis
suivez nous également sur notre
plateforme Public Sénat point fr doit y
avoir un peu d'intelligence artificielle
dedans